haha the Joe Rogan experience I'm the
happiest when I'm working really hard
right and when it's done like when you
make one of those videos and then you
get a bunch of positive feedback from it
that's kind of the amazingly satisfying
yeah I'm gonna do it for free
and I also like her Metzger help with
that last one
well Kurt's but Kurt's [ __ ] hilarious
he's great
and we're doing we're working on making
a show and it's like we're working so
hard and no one needs even asking for
bits it's really satisfying and I feel
like about the money you just keep doing
those goddamn Instagram videos if you
can just keep doing them
I think it's undeniable it's so good
some of those are so good they're so
mean yes Panera I know yeah well Bill
Maher asper I mean he I didn't want to
make a video Bill Maher getting
gangbanged but he came on this program
he said my impression sucks
what am I supposed to do sit there
listen I'm on your side with that one he
was impressed by the way it's very it's
very funny he should be laughing at that
that [ __ ] was hilarious you hate
someone's impression you have to pretend
you like there's no good saying you
can't lie you can't say it's not good
it's really good won't lie well that he
when you said I'll let's play it he was
like I'm leaving if you put he's like
threatened to leave you plate it and by
the way and I don't want it I'm really
no more I like having a nemesis it's
kind of feels good so like Bill Maher oh
yeah I like I'm the rants that he's been
doing during kovat have been the very
best you know the rants that he does the
beginning of his show I have all their
great man
they're great he's doing him with no
audience but they've been really funny
and really good points
it's like he's actually ramped it up
during this pandemic his some of those
beginning of the show rants are
excellent he's great writers they got a
great writers fan it's a it's a you know
it's a treasure that shows a national
treasure but he did get B did he get
gangbanged in my video in your video
your campaign
also things together exactly but also he
acted like alright anyway yes it exists
he went to Hawaii with him in his
private plane yes I don't know him now
in his defense I'm sure I was invisible
to him and he forgot me
but like the beach went to dinners and
and then you kind of got because he did
know about the videos and he told you he
didn't and then he kind of anyway listen
listen visit I get it he but I think in
all do with all due respect I think he's
just looking at it the wrong way I think
it's funny and I think it doesn't make
him any less brilliant
it doesn't make you show any less great
and the show is great I think we both
admit it
those rants are brilliant they're
brilliant I love his rants I've I've
tweeted a few of them out and said like
Bravo I tweeted him out it paid me to
make a video where he was getting
gangbanged hurt it hurt me I didn't want
to do it it should it's so funny man
it's so funny and this is coming from a
guy who's a fan of Bill Maher I was
laughing hard though I love that you
showed your wife and she's like what's
wrong with you know it's different
tastes different strokes but yeah it is
but it's also like come on man
if you lighten up it's almost all funny
I've been a doctor in a while knock on
wood I feel pretty healthy I used to I
was diagnosed with celiac disease gonna
be in the doctor after Bill Maher finds
you should I be scared of him should be
might get Russell with you what would
Bill Maher do it's funny don't shoot my
dick with cocaine huh okay people
here comes cocaine into your [ __ ] okay
you [ __ ] it's so good that's such a good
impression anyone says it's not a good
impression
come on man I mean I do a lot of
impressions they're not all good I some
are like pretty I think my Elan is
pretty weak but my pretty good your
bills pretty good it's very good Caitlyn
Jenner is her that's her voice now I
can't see her any other way she was well
she does that because she's I think
she's a loan on she answers her
yeah she'll be like and what you get
some shoes yeah and she's going yeah I
bought some Jimmy Choos yeah and yeah
how weird
where's Kim
[Applause]